With the holiday season about to begin, it's a show about holidays and milestones of all kinds. Today's This American Life was taped a few years back in front of a live audience.
随着假期即将到来，这一期节目我们将探讨各种节日和里程碑。今天的《美国生活》（This American Life）是几年前在现场观众面前录制的。
When the big day finally arrives, the day you've been waiting for, it's like the invisible is made visible. And sometimes you look at it and you think, that's it?
当那个重要日子终于到来，那个你一直在等待的日子，就像原本不可见的事物变得可见了。有时你看着它，心里会想，就这？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For weeks before his 11th birthday, Jason wanted a party at a roller rink with all his friends. He had never had a birthday party, so he invites 11 friends, gets their RSVPs, and comes the big day, the party room at the roller rink is his.
在11岁生日前的几周，杰森一直想要在旱冰场和朋友们办一场派对。他以前从没办过生日派对，于是他邀请了11个朋友，收到了他们的回复，大日子终于到了，旱冰场的派对室也准备好了。
And we waited around, we waited around. And we're waiting there for around a half hour, and none of my friends, none of the invited guests had arrived. And so they put us in the room and my mom asked me, well, where is everybody? Where is everybody? And I say, Ma, I don't know where everybody is. Well, didn't they say they'd be here? Yeah, they said they'd be here.
然后我们就在那儿等啊等。我们等了大约半个小时，没有一个朋友，没有一个受邀的客人出现。后来他们把我们带进房间，我妈妈问我，大家都去哪儿了？大家在哪儿？我说，妈，我不知道大家在哪儿。噢，他们没说会来吗？说了，他们说会来的。
I have this vivid, vivid image marked on my brain of a table and 10 chairs around the table and all of these sundaes, these white sundaes with hot fudge on them. 10 empty chairs. 10 uneaten sundaes.
我脑海中至今还清晰地印着那幅画面：一张桌子，周围摆着10把椅子，桌上放着所有的圣代，那些融化了的白色圣代，上面淋着热巧克力酱。10把空椅子。10份没被吃掉的圣代。
It's like The Last Supper but if none of the apostles made it.
就像《最后的晚餐》，只不过所有的门徒都没来。
Exactly.
没错。
To this day, Jason still cannot explain it. He had friends at school, he was always picked first for kickball. The next year his cat, a cat that was the same age as he was, died on his birthday. Another year, his aunts and uncles accidentally set fire to the back of his house.
直到今天，杰森仍然无法解释这件事。他在学校里有朋友，踢球时总被第一个选中。第二年，他的猫——一只和他同龄的猫——在他的生日那天死了。又一年，他的姑姑和叔叔们不小心烧了他家后院。
In preparing for today's program, I have heard lots of horrifying birthday stories. Matt was robbed on his birthday. Lynn's home was destroyed by an earthquake. Sarah had a tree that was planted the day she was born. And on her 17th birthday, lightning hit the tree. It burned to the ground. How do you not see that as symbolic of something?
为了准备今天的节目，我听到了许多可怕的生日故事。马特在生日那天被抢劫了。琳恩的家在地震中被毁了。萨拉出生那天种了一棵树。在她17岁生日时，闪电击中了那棵树。它烧成了灰烬。你怎么能不觉得这象征着什么呢？
Years after Jason's party at the roller rink, the one where nobody showed up, his girlfriend still asks him about it. And she asks him about it a lot. It must explain something about who he is today.
在杰森旱冰场派对多年后，也就是那个没人出席的派对，他的女朋友仍然会问他这件事。而且她问得很频繁。这一定能解释他今天为什么是这样的人。
And I have to point out again that I don't think, at least, that I was a loser when I was growing up. But the thing is, as much as I say that, it happened. I had this birthday party that only one person went to. And that's going to hold stronger than anything that I could possibly say to convince you that I was not a loser.
我必须再次重申，我不认为——至少我觉得——我成长过程中是个失败者。但问题是，尽管我这么说，这件事确实发生了。我办了那场生日派对，却只有一个人参加。比起我为了证明自己不是失败者而说的任何话，这件事的影响力都要大得多。
Certain days have symbolic meaning whether we want them to or not. That's why it's important, I think, to overcompensate, to go big, throw a huge party, surround yourself with people, make a lot of noise. That is why, my friends, today, on the fifth anniversary of our radio show, we have come out here to be with you in this huge theater. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
无论我们是否愿意，某些日子都具有象征意义。我想，这就是为什么我们需要过度补偿，大张旗鼓地办场盛大的派对，让自己被人群簇拥，制造巨大的声响。这就是为什么，朋友们，今天在我们电台节目开播五周年之际，我们来到这里与你们共聚在这个巨大的剧场。这里是WBEZ芝加哥和公共广播国际台制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Our program recorded today on a four-city tour of New York, Boston, Chicago, and Los Angeles. A co-production with radio stations WNYC, WBUR, WBEZ, and KCRW. Many, many thanks to them.
我们的节目今天是在纽约、波士顿、芝加哥和洛杉矶四城市巡回录制的。这是与WNYC、WBUR、WBEZ和KCRW广播电台的联合制作。非常感谢他们。
Today on our program, birthdays, anniversaries, milestones of all sorts, and what do they really mean anyway? Act One, Pilgrim's Progress. Sarah Vowell takes over the family Thanksgiving dinner by bringing everyone to New York City. Babies cryin', birds a-dyin', people sighin', Ellis Island. Islan'. Act Two, Kodak Moments of the Dead, the story of a young funeral director who is updating one of our most sacred and oldest rituals of commemoration, doing something that even other funeral directors find very, very strange. Act Three, Birthday Gift. Russell Banks has a story that unfolds so cleanly and pleasingly that really, I have to say, the less said about it at this point, the better. Music throughout our hour from Chicago pop music sensation OK Go. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是生日、周年纪念、各种里程碑，以及它们到底意味着什么？第一幕，《天路历程》。萨拉·沃威尔带着大家来到纽约市，接管了家庭感恩节晚餐。婴儿在哭，鸟儿在死，人们在叹息，埃利斯岛。第二幕，《死亡的柯达时刻》，这是一个年轻的殡葬承办人的故事，他正在更新我们最神圣、最古老的纪念仪式之一，做着甚至连其他殡葬承办人都觉得非常、非常奇怪的事情。第三幕，《生日礼物》。罗素·班克斯带来的故事展开得如此简洁动人，我不得不说，此时此刻说得越少越好。整个节目期间的音乐由芝加哥流行音乐新星OK Go提供。请继续收听。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Act One, Pilgrim's Progress. We are a nation whose national holidays are usually more about getting together with family and friends than actually commemorating the past. When Labor Day rolls around, I do not think that many of us review the history of Haymarket Square or the fight for the eight-hour work day. Even in this crowd.
第一幕，《天路历程》。我们这个国家的国定假日，通常更多是为了与家人朋友团聚，而不是为了真正纪念过去。当劳动节到来时，我想我们中很少有人会回顾干草市场广场的历史或争取八小时工作制的斗争。即使在现场的各位也是如此。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I will confess that I was actually well into my 20s before I fully understood that Veterans Day and Memorial Day are actually two separate holidays with separate meanings and not just one holiday that comes around a lot. This does not mean that our big national holidays do not contain deep, commemorative meaning to us. It's just, I think, that the meaning is often personal. Sarah Vowell is one of our contributing editors, and she says this year, her family broke with all its traditions on Thanksgiving and launched into an entirely new era as a family. Please welcome her.
我承认，我直到20多岁才完全理解退伍军人节和阵亡将士纪念日其实是两个不同的节日，有着不同的意义，而不是仅仅一个频繁出现的假日。这并不意味着我们的大型国定假日对我们没有深刻的纪念意义。只是，我认为这种意义往往是个人的。萨拉·沃威尔是我们的一位特约编辑，她说今年她的家庭在感恩节打破了所有传统，开启了家庭的新纪元。欢迎她。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
When I invited my mom and dad to come to New York City to have Thanksgiving at my house, I never expected them to say yes. Not only had they never been to New York, they had never been east of the Mississippi, nor had they ever visited me. I've always had these fantasies about being in a normal family in which the parents come to town and their adult daughter spends their entire visit daydreaming of suicide. I'm here to tell you that dreams really do come true.
当我邀请父母来纽约市我家过感恩节时，我从没指望他们会答应。他们不仅从未去过纽约，甚至从未去过密西西比河以东，也从未探望过我。我一直幻想自己身处一个正常的家庭，父母进城探望，而成年女儿整天都在做着自杀的白日梦。我在这里告诉大家，梦想真的会成真。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was terrified we wouldn't have enough to talk about. In the interest of harmony, there's a tacit agreement in my family. The following subjects are best avoided in any conversation longer than a minute and a half-- national politics, state and local politics, any music by any person who never headlined at the Grand Ole Opry, my personal life, and their so-called God.
我当时非常担心我们没有足够的话题可聊。为了保持和谐，我们家有一个默认协议。以下主题最好在任何超过一分半钟的谈话中避免提及——国家政治、州和地方政治、任何从未登上“大奥普里剧院”舞台的音乐人的作品、我的私生活，以及他们所谓的上帝。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Five whole days. When I visit them back home in Montana, conversation isn't a problem because we go to the movies every afternoon. That way, we can be together but without the burden of actually talking to each other. Tommy Lee Jones does the talking for us. Bless his heart, that is a public service.
整整五天。当我在蒙大拿州老家探望他们时，谈话不成问题，因为我们每天下午都去看电影。这样，我们既能在一起，又不必承担真正交谈的负担。汤米·李·琼斯替我们说了话。感谢上帝，那简直是一种公共服务。
But my sister Amy is bringing her, shall we say, lively seven-month-old son Owen along, so the cinema is not an option. Which means five days together, just us, no movies. We are headed into uncharted and possibly hostile lands, pioneers in a new world. It is Thanksgiving. The Pilgrims had the Mayflower. I buy a gravy boat.
但我姐姐艾米带着她那“活泼”的七个月大的儿子欧文一起来，所以看电影不是选择了。这意味着我们要在没有电影的情况下在一起待五天。我们正进入一片未知的、可能是充满敌意的土地，就像新世界的拓荒者。这是感恩节。清教徒有“五月花号”，而我买了一个肉汁船。
It's lucky that Amy's coming with Mom and Dad. Amy still lives six blocks away from them in Bozeman. She would act as interpreter and go-between among my parents and me. Like Squanto.
幸运的是艾米和父母一起过来。艾米仍然住在博兹曼离他们六个街区远的地方。她可以充当我和父母之间的翻译和调解人。就像斯匡托一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Amy's husband Jay has decided to stay home in Montana to go deer hunting with his brother. Everyone else arrives at my apartment in Chelsea. Amy and Owen are bunking with me, so I walk my parents around the corner to check them into their hotel on 23rd. "Here we are," says Mom, stopping under the awning of the Chelsea Hotel. There she stands, a woman whose favorite book is called, simply, Matthew--
艾米的丈夫杰伊决定留在蒙大拿州，和他哥哥去猎鹿。其他人抵达我位于切尔西的公寓。艾米和欧文跟我一起住，所以我带父母转过拐角去切尔西酒店登记入住。“我们到了，”妈妈停在切尔西酒店的遮阳棚下说道。她站在那里，一个最喜欢的书名简单地叫《马太福音》的女人——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--right on the spot where the cops hauled Sid Vicious out in handcuffs after his girlfriend was found stabbed to death on their hotel room floor. "No, mother," I say, taking her arm and directing her down the block to the Chelsea Savoy, a hotel where they go to the trouble to clean the rooms each day.
——就站在那个警察将席德·维瑟斯戴上手铐带走的地方，就在他的女友被发现死在酒店房间地板上之后。“不，妈妈，”我说，挽起她的手臂，把她引向街区下方的切尔西萨沃伊酒店，那是一家每天都会费心打扫房间的酒店。
It is around this time, oh, 20 minutes into their trip, that my dad starts making wisecracks like, "boy, kid, bet you can't wait 'til we're out of here." My father, a man who moved us 1,600 miles away from our Oklahoma relatives so he wouldn't have to see them anymore, makes a joke, on average, every two hours he is here about how much I'm anticipating the second they'll say goodbye. I find this charming, but so disturbingly true I don't know what to say.
大约就在这时，也就是他们旅程开始20分钟后，我爸爸开始讲一些俏皮话，比如，“嘿，孩子，敢打赌你肯定巴不得我们赶紧离开吧。”我父亲是个曾把我们带到离俄克拉荷马州亲戚1600英里远的地方，以至于再也不用见到他们的人，他平均每待两个小时就会开个玩笑，说我是多么期待他们离开的那一秒。我觉得这很迷人，但也令人不安地真实，以至于我不知道该说什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
By halfway through the first day, I discover I needn't have worried about what we would talk about with the baby preventing us from seeing movies. When you have a baby around, the baby is the movie. We occupy an entire entertaining hour just on drool, non-narrative drool. Then there's the sightseeing. First stop, Ellis Island. The thing about going to Ellis Island is that it's a lot like going to Ellis Island.
第一天过了一半，我发现自己根本不必担心在没有电影的情况下聊什么。当家里有个婴儿时，婴儿就是电影。我们仅仅花了一个小时看他在那儿流口水，毫无叙事性的流口水，就足够打发时间了。还有观光。第一站，埃利斯岛。去埃利斯岛的事情就是，它就像去埃利斯岛一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Perhaps to help you better understand the immigrant experience, they make you stand in line for the crammed ferry for an hour and a half in the windy cold. By the time we step onto the island, we are huddled masses yearning to be free. Our great-grandmother Ellen passed through here on her way from Sweden. We watch a video on the health inspections given to immigrants, walk past oodles of photos of men in hats and women in shawls.
也许是为了让你更好地理解移民经历，他们会让你在寒风中排一个半小时队去挤渡轮。当我们踏上岛屿时，我们成了渴望自由的蜷缩人群。我们的曾祖母艾伦在从瑞典出发的途中经过这里。我们观看了一段关于给移民进行健康检查的视频，走过无数张戴着帽子、披着披肩的男男女女的照片。
Though no one says anything, I know my father and mother and sister are thinking what I'm thinking. They're thinking about when we moved away from Oklahoma to Montana, how unknown that was, how strange and lonesome. I read a letter in a display case that says, "and I never saw my mother again." And I think of my grandfather, how we just drove off, leaving him behind, waving to us in the rear-view mirror. And here we are in New York, because here I am in New York. Because ever since Ellen's father brought her here, every generation moves away from the one before.
虽然没人说话，但我知道我父亲、母亲和姐姐都在想我正在想的事。他们正在想我们搬离俄克拉荷马州去蒙大拿州的时候，那种未知、那种陌生和孤独。我在展示柜里读到一封信，上面写着：“我再也没见过我的母亲。”我想到了我的祖父，我们是如何开车离去，把他留在身后，他在后视镜里向我们挥手。而现在我们身在纽约，因为我就在纽约。因为自从艾伦的父亲带她来到这里，每一代人都远离了前一代人。
It is curious that we Americans have a holiday, Thanksgiving, that's all about people who left their homes for a life of their own choosing, a life that was different from their parents' lives. And how do we celebrate it? By hanging out with our parents. It's as if on the 4th of July, we honored our independence from the British by playing cricket and nibbling on crumpets.
奇怪的是，我们美国人有一个节日——感恩节，全是关于那些为了自己选择的生活而离开家园的人，一种不同于父母的生活。我们是怎么庆祝它的呢？通过和父母厮混。这就好像在7月4日，我们通过打板球和啃烤饼来庆祝我们脱离英国独立一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Thanksgiving morning, my parents take Owen to see the Macy's parade while Amy and I start making dinner. Let me repeat that. My mother leaves while I cook, specifically cornbread dressing, a dish my mother has made every Thanksgiving since before I was born. To her credit, she has not inquired about my process since she phoned to ask me if she should bring cornmeal in her suitcase. As an Okie, my mom only uses white cornmeal processed by the Shawnee Company in Muskogee. She does not even consider my cornbread to be cornbread at all, because I make it with yellow cornmeal and-- heresy-- sugar. "You don't make cornbread," she told me in the same deflated voice she uses to describe my hair--
感恩节那天早上，父母带欧文去看梅西百货游行，我和艾米开始做晚餐。请允许我重复一遍。妈妈在我做饭时离开了，特别是做玉米面包配料，这是我从出生前妈妈每年感恩节都会做的菜。值得称赞的是，自从她打电话问我是否应该在行李箱里带玉米粉以来，她就没再过问我的做法。作为俄克拉荷马人，我妈妈只用马斯科吉肖尼公司加工的白玉米粉。她甚至根本不把我的玉米面包当成玉米面包，因为我用的是黄玉米粉，而且——大逆不道——还加了糖。“你做的不是玉米面包，”她用那道描述我发型时的泄气语调对我说——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--"you make Jonnycake."
——“你做的是乔尼蛋糕。”
I'm standing at the cutting board chopping sage, and it hits me what it means that she's letting me be in charge of the dressing-- I am going to die. Being in charge of the dressing means you're a grown-up for real. And being a grown-up for real means you're getting old. And getting old means you are definitely, finally, totally going to die. My mother is a grandmother, and my sister is a mother, and I have decided the dressing will be yellow this year, therefore we'll all be dead someday. Happy holidays!
我站在砧板前切着鼠尾草，突然意识到她让我负责做配料意味着什么——我要死了。负责配料意味着你真的是个成年人了。而成为真正的成年人意味着你在变老。而变老意味着你绝对、最终、彻底地会死。我妈妈是祖母，我姐姐是母亲，而我决定今年的配料要用黄色的，所以我们终有一天都会死。节日快乐！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have invited two of my New York friends to join us for dinner, and I was a little nervous about how everyone would get along. To my delight, the meal is smooth and congenial. My friends and I talk about the West Nile Virus killing birds on Long Island. My father counters with a lovely anecdote about an open copper pit in Butte that filled up with contaminated rainwater and killed 250 geese in one day. There's nothing like eating one dead bird and talking about a bunch of other dead birds to really bring people together.
我邀请了两位纽约朋友参加晚餐，我有点担心大家能否相处融洽。让我高兴的是，这顿饭吃得很顺利，气氛融洽。我和朋友谈论杀死长岛鸟类的西尼罗河病毒。我父亲则反击讲述了一个关于比特市一个露天铜矿的可爱轶事，里面充满了被污染的雨水，一天之内杀死了250只鹅。没有什么比吃着一只死鸟，同时谈论一群其他死鸟更能把人们团结在一起了。
The next morning, right about the time Owen starts to cry while simultaneously my mother jams the bathroom door and my father's on his hands and knees prying it open with a penknife, a cloud passes over me. Once or twice a day, I am enveloped inside what I like to call the impenetrable shield of melancholy. This shield, it is impenetrable, hence the name. I cannot speak. And while I can feel myself freeze up, I can't do anything about it.
第二天早上，就在欧文开始哭闹，同时妈妈卡在浴室门里，爸爸跪在地上用钢笔刀撬门的时候，一朵乌云笼罩了我。每天一两次，我会被我所谓的“难以穿透的忧郁盾牌”所笼罩。这个盾牌，它是难以穿透的，因此得名。我说不出话来。虽然我能感觉到自己僵住了，却无能为力。
Everybody in the family goes through these little spells. I just happen to be the spooky one at this particular moment. When people ask me if I'm the black sheep of the family, I always say that no, we're all black sheep. Every few hours they're here, I look over at my dad nervously crunching his fingers together. If he were at home for Thanksgiving, he'd be ignoring us and spending all his time in his shop. The thing that unites us is that all four of us are homebody claustrophobes who prefer to be alone and are suspicious of other people.
家里的每个人都会经历这些小插曲。只是在这个时刻，我碰巧是那个阴沉的一个。当人们问我是否是家里的害群之马时，我总是说不，我们全家都是害群之马。他们在这里的每隔几个小时，我都会看到父亲紧张地揉捏着手指。如果他在家过感恩节，他会无视我们，整天待在店里。把我们团结在一起的原因是，我们四个都是居家恐聚症患者，更喜欢独自待着，对其他人持怀疑态度。
So the trait that binds us together as a family, preferring to keep to ourselves, makes it difficult to be together as a family. Paradoxically, it's at these times that I feel closest to them, that I understand them best, that I love them most. It's just surprising we ever breed.
所以，把我们作为一个家庭联系在一起的特质——喜欢独处——反而使我们作为一家人待在一起变得困难。讽刺的是，正是在这些时刻，我感到与他们最亲近，我最了解他们，也最爱他们。只是令人惊讶的是我们居然还能繁衍。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The next day, we do the most typical thing we could possibly do as a family. We split up. By the time we all reconvene on Saturday evening, my ragged mother becomes so ambitious with her sightseeing that I can tell she's decided that she's never coming back. "You guys want to go to Rockefeller Center?" I ask. And she says, "yeah, because who knows when I'll be back again? Ditto the Empire State Building, because who knows when I'll be back again?"
第二天，我们做了作为一家人能做的最典型的事情。我们分开了。当我们在周六晚上重新集合时，我那疲惫的母亲变得对观光非常有野心，我看得出她决定了她再也不会回来了。“你们想去洛克菲勒中心吗？”我问。她说：“想，因为谁知道我什么时候会再来？”帝国大厦也一样，因为谁知道我什么时候会再来？
If any of you are visiting the Empire State Building, may I offer some advice? If you are waiting in the very long line for the very last elevator, and an attendant says that anyone who wants to walk up the last six flights may do so now, right away, and you are with your aging parents and a sister who is carrying a child the size of a fax machine, stay in line for the elevator. But if you must take the stairs, go first and do not look back. Otherwise, your parents will look like one of those Renaissance frescoes of Adam and Eve being expelled from the Garden of Eden, all hunched over and afraid.
如果你们中有人要参观帝国大厦，我可以给点建议吗？如果你正在为最后一台电梯排着长队，而工作人员说任何想走上最后六层楼的人现在就可以去，而你带着年迈的父母和一个抱着像传真机那么大孩子的姐姐，就待在电梯队里吧。但如果你非得走楼梯，先走，别回头。否则，你的父母看起来就像那些文艺复兴壁画中被逐出伊甸园的亚当和夏娃，全都佝偻着背，充满了恐惧。
So we make it to the observation deck, Brooklyn to the south of us, New Jersey to the west. Places that people fled to from far away. Places that people now run away from to make another life. It's dark and cold and windy, and we're sweaty from climbing the stairs. It's really pretty, though. And there we stand, side by side, sharing a thought like the family we are. My sister wishes she were home, my mom and dad wish they were home, I wish they were home, too. Thank you.
我们终于到达了观景台，南边是布鲁克林，西边是新泽西。那是人们从远方逃离的地方。那是人们现在为了开始新生活而逃离的地方。天很黑，很冷，风很大，我们爬楼梯爬得满身大汗。不过这里真的很美。我们就这样肩并肩站着，分享着一个想法，就像我们作为一家人一样。我姐姐想家，我父母想家，我也想他们回家。谢谢你们。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC - "BYE BYE BABY" BY OK GO]
[音乐 - OK Go演唱的“BYE BYE BABY”]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
OK Go.
OK Go。
Act Two, Kodak Moments of the Dead. Not long ago, one of our producers, Starlee Kine, went to the funeral of a relative of hers in Los Angeles. There were four eulogies, and it was Starlee's grandmother, Goldie, who did a grand stem-winder of a speech, inspiring and moving and heartfelt.
第二幕，《死亡的柯达时刻》。不久前，我们的制片人之一斯塔莉·凯恩去洛杉矶参加了一位亲戚的葬礼。当时有四篇悼词，是斯塔莉的祖母戈尔迪发表了一场精彩的、鼓舞人心、感人至深的长篇演讲。
So Goldie finishes and sits back down between her 88-year-old sister, Viv, on one side and Starlee on the other. And then, on a big TV screen in front of the chapel, a video begins. The grandmother cannot believe it. She nudges her sister Viv, stage whispering, "have you ever?"
戈尔迪讲完后，坐回了她88岁的妹妹薇薇和斯塔莉中间。然后，礼堂前方的一块大电视屏幕上，开始播放一段视频。祖母简直不敢相信。她推了推妹妹薇薇，舞台耳语道：“你见过吗？”
On screen are pictures of the deceased. Black and white on the beach is a young man, a wedding shot with his wife, the obligatory goofy shot of him in a dress with his buddies. The photos were selected by the family and set to a musical soundtrack, which was also selected by the family. These being Jews-- my people-- as you might guess, there's only one real choice about the music, really no choice at all.
屏幕上是逝者的照片。黑白色的海滩照，与妻子的婚礼照，以及那张他在朋友陪同下穿着女装的必不可少的傻气照片。这些照片由家人精选，并配上了同样由家人选择的背景音乐。既然这都是犹太人——我的族人——你们可能猜到了，音乐其实只有一个真正的选择，其实根本没得选。
[MUSIC - "MEMORY" BY BARBRA STREISAND]
[音乐 - 芭芭拉·史翠珊演唱的“MEMORY”]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Barbra. Auntie Viv audibly exclaims, "oy vey!" Grandma Goldie responds, "oy, Viv!" But here's the thing, people are crying. They're crying more than they cried during the eulogies. And later, after the burial, back at the house, everybody watches the video over and over. They laugh, they cry, they rewind, they replay. Barbra hasn't had a hit like this since Yentl.
芭芭拉。薇薇阿姨大声惊呼：“天呐！”戈尔迪祖母回应道：“噢，薇薇！”但问题是，人们在哭。他们哭得比悼词环节还要厉害。后来，在葬礼结束后，回到家里，每个人一遍又一遍地看这段视频。他们笑，他们哭，他们倒带，他们重播。芭芭拉自从《燕特尔》之后就没出过这么火的单曲了。
So I want to visit the cemetery where all this happens, where the cost of a grave or a crypt includes a personalized video to be shown at your funeral, to be posted for eternity on the internet, to be viewed on video screens scattered semi-tastefully throughout the cemetery grounds.
所以我想去那个发生这一切的墓地，在那里，墓地或墓穴的费用包括为你葬礼展示的个性化视频，该视频将永远发布在互联网上，并在散布在墓地各处的视频屏幕上播放，显得半高雅。
This whole scheme is the brainchild of the impossibly young and impossibly handsome Tyler Cassity and his brother Brent. They grew up in St. Louis, their dad was also in the funeral business, and they bought a rundown Hollywood cemetery three years ago, when Tyler was 27, and renamed it Hollywood Forever. Funerals, mind you, present the same questions that any anniversary or milestone presents. How do you mark the passing of time? How do you capture the span of a life so it can be commemorated and remembered?
这个整个方案是极其年轻且极其英俊的泰勒·卡西蒂和他的兄弟布伦特的心血结晶。他们在圣路易斯长大，他们的父亲也从事殡葬业，三年前，也就是泰勒27岁时，他们买下了一座破败的洛杉矶好莱坞墓地，并将其重新命名为“好莱坞永恒”。请记住，葬礼提出了任何纪念日或里程碑都会提出的相同问题。你如何标记时间的流逝？你如何捕捉人的一生，以便进行纪念和缅怀？
And Tyler says that the way that most American funerals address this question is with a ritual in technology that had not really changed very much since the Civil War. The big innovation during the Civil War was embalming. Embalming preserved a person's body for a week or so while you shipped them home from a battlefield. But during the Civil War, it became widespread, and it popularized this kind of funeral, the kind that we know today, where the body is dressed up and put on display during the service.
泰勒说，大多数美国葬礼处理这个问题的方式，是使用一种自南北战争以来就没怎么改变过的仪式和技术。南北战争期间的重大创新是防腐。防腐处理可以将人的遗体保存一周左右，以便你从战场运回家。但在南北战争期间，它变得普遍，并普及了我们今天所知道的这种葬礼，即遗体被穿戴整齐，在仪式上公开展示。
You want to pump fluid into that body so it seems kind of life-like, pink fluid. And you want to paint the face. A mortician feels like he's succeeded if the family says, "look, he looks so alive." Whereas our enhancement to that is that you show video of the person, media, media that in some way has captured life. And that media is 100 times stronger than an altered body.
你想往那具躯体里注入液体，使其看起来有点像活人，粉红色的液体。你想给脸部化妆。如果家属说，“看，他看起来真像活着一样，”殡葬师就会觉得他成功了。而我们的改进在于展示这个人的视频，媒体，某种程度上已经捕捉到生命的媒体。这种媒体比经过处理的躯体要强大100倍。
Our colleagues rebelled at the idea of having any type of screen in a chapel or near a body. And yet they were holding tight to this tradition of embalming and face painting and extreme doctoring of the body to try and make it look alive. The moment we put a screen in there, from that moment on, there was always a huge increase in the emotion of that service. That's when you started to have everyone crying, that's when you started to have laughter, tears, celebration. That screen, once you put that in there, the whole thing changed.
我们的同事反对在礼堂里或遗体附近放置任何屏幕的想法。然而，他们紧紧抓住防腐和面部化妆以及对遗体进行极端修补以使其看起来像活人的传统不放。那一刻，当我们把屏幕放进去时，从那一刻起，该服务的仪式感始终有巨大的提升。那是你开始看到每个人都在哭的时候，那是你开始看到笑声、眼泪、庆祝的时候。那块屏幕，一旦你放进去，整件事就变了。
Good morning, good afternoon, good evening. Whenever you listen to this, you will hear the voices of your ever-loving mother and your dear father, normally known as Mom and Dad.
早上好，下午好，晚上好。无论你何时听到这段录音，你都会听到你永远爱你的母亲和你亲爱的父亲的声音，通常称为妈妈和爸爸。
This is a video made of a kindly and endearing couple named Dorothy and Lester Schaffer They're sitting on lawn chairs in their backyard. It's not bad. They're affectionate, they goad each other on, they are genuinely funny. We hear, for example, the story of how the Schaffers met, on a school trip to the zoo.
这是一段由一对善良又可爱的夫妇多萝西和莱斯特·沙弗制作的视频。他们坐在后院的草坪椅上。这不算太差。他们很有感情，互相戏弄，真的很幽默。我们听到了，例如，沙弗夫妇是在去动物园的学校旅行中相遇的故事。
Really. On the path between the bear pits and the monkey cage.
真的。在熊坑和猴笼之间的小路上。
Right between the bear pits and the monkey cage. Well, we started dating then. And every time we'd have a date--
就在熊坑和猴笼之间。我们从那时开始约会。而且每次我们有约会——
It rained.
都在下雨。
--it rained. I used to call her "my raindrop."
——都在下雨。我常叫她“我的雨滴”。
As it turns out, in deciding to make videos which somehow capture what somebody is all about to preserve for eternity, Tyler and his brother have accidentally stumbled on a rather difficult artistic project. You get a sense of the Schaffers on their video, but only because of their own force of personality. They're charming. Most of the videos made at the cemetery lack this kind of character, so much so that it reminds you just how hard it is to do, to capture somebody on film.
事实证明，在决定制作能以某种方式捕捉某人的一切以便流芳百世的视频时，泰勒和他的兄弟意外地撞进了一个相当困难的艺术项目。你从视频中能感受到沙弗夫妇，但这仅仅是因为他们自身的人格力量。他们很有魅力。在墓地制作的大多数视频缺乏这种性格，以至于让你想起在胶片上捕捉某人是多么困难。
At times, your heart goes out to the people in the videos. For instance, when they're asked by the filmmakers to leave a message to the future, you can almost see the flop sweat from the other side. What would you say on the spot, really? This next clip is from a video made by a 40-ish man, who's actually still alive, named Steve Goldstein, who was asked to leave a few words of wisdom to the future.
有时，你会对视频中的人们心生怜悯。例如，当他们被电影制作人要求给未来留下信息时，你几乎可以看到另一边的冷汗。当场你会说什么，真的？下一个片段来自一个名为史蒂夫·戈尔茨坦的40多岁男人制作的视频，他实际上还活着，他被要求留下几句给未来的智慧之言。
I guess if I had to say something along those lines, it would be the most important thing in life is to learn to love each other, learn to get along, respect each other, respect each other's differences, appreciate your differences, celebrate your failures as much as your successes because that's how you grow. You can't succeed without failing.
我想如果我必须说些什么，那将是生活中最重要的是学会彼此相爱，学会和睦相处，相互尊重，尊重彼此的差异，欣赏你们的差异，庆祝你的失败正如庆祝成功一样，因为那是你成长的方式。没有失败，你就无法成功。
He continues with aphorisms like this for a while, ending with--
他继续说着这样的格言，结尾说——
My life's been great. I have no regrets. I honestly have no regrets. Except for some mistake I made on a game show once, a long time ago. I could have won a lot of money. Aside from that, I have no regrets.
我的人生很棒。我没有遗憾。我真的没有遗憾。除了很久以前我在游戏节目中犯的一个错误。我本可以赢得很多钱。除此之外，我没有遗憾。
Doing these, it's kind of like a robot. They come, they go. I do the next one. It's kind of like I'm a machine. I just do it. So our emotions are kind of gone.
做这些，有点像机器人。他们来，他们走。我做下一个。感觉我就像一台机器。我只是做。所以我们的情绪某种程度上消失了。
Norman Brown is one of three editors who assemble these videos at computer workstations in a big, high-ceilinged room on the cemetery grounds. The feeling part of the job is done by women, four women, who talk with the families, gather photos, and give shot-by-shot instructions to the editors. As video production goes, this is factory work. 90% of the videos are cut-and-paste jobs, just a series of photos which appear on screen for 10 seconds each with a pop song on the soundtrack, thrown together in a few hours after somebody dies to play at the funeral service. Often a family member narrates, explaining what the pictures are.
诺曼·布朗是墓地场地内一间高大房间里的三位编辑之一，他们负责在电脑工作站组装这些视频。工作中带感情的部分由女性完成，四名女性与家属交流，收集照片，并向编辑提供逐条指令。作为视频制作，这属于工厂流水线作业。90%的视频都是剪切粘贴的活儿，只是一系列出现在屏幕上的照片，每张10秒，配上一首流行歌曲，在某人去世后几小时内拼凑出来，在葬礼上播放。通常由家庭成员叙述，解释这些照片是什么。
Do people ever say, "well, my dad was a drunk?"
人们有没有说，“嗯，我爸爸是个酒鬼？”
No. Nothing like that. Nothing at all.
没有。没有那种事。完全没有。
"We had a hard time seeing eye to eye. We didn't always get along. I think they were disappointed in me sometimes."
“我们很难达成一致。我们并不总是相处得很好。我觉得他们有时对我感到失望。”
No, none of that. We don't get any, "oh, he was a drug addict, he was an unfit father."
不，都没有。我们得不到任何“噢，他是个瘾君子，他是个不称职的父亲”之类的话。
"He wasn't always faithful to my mom."
“他对我妈妈并不总是忠诚。”
No. We have no affairs. We've had none of that. They don't say, "yeah, he was a horn dog," or anything. Just everything is positive.
不。我们没有外遇。我们没有那种事。他们不会说，“是的，他是个花花公子”或什么。一切都是正面的。
Which seems, I have to say, completely appropriate to the occasion and the task at hand at any milestone event-- an anniversary, a birthday, a funeral, even a national holiday. I think we do not want the whole picture. I think we want a pretty picture.
我不得不说，这似乎完全适合任何里程碑事件——周年纪念、生日、葬礼，甚至是国定假日。我认为我们想要的不是全貌。我认为我们想要的是一张漂亮的图画。
I don't we're dealing with honesty in this. This is not the whole. You've got to look at the purpose of, what is the purpose of your going to this funeral?
我不认为我们在处理诚实问题。这不是全貌。你得看看目的，你参加这个葬礼的目的是什么？
At that moment, at that funereal moment, at that moment of death, we do want as much good as we can. And we do want as many good memories as we can.
在那一刻，在那葬礼时刻，在那死亡时刻，我们确实想要尽可能多的美好。而且我们确实想要尽可能多的美好回忆。
Tyler Cassity says that it's hard enough to get through the death of someone we love. Of course this is what we want. Tyler and his brother have only been making funeral videos for a few years. And they definitely see it as a work in progress, something that they're still figuring out. But all this thinking about how you preserve memories has led Tyler to start collecting his own scrapbooks, documenting his own life. He keeps two of these photo albums in his office. And when I ask him to flip through the pages, he comes to one photo which leads him to tell this story.
泰勒·卡西蒂说，要度过我们所爱之人的死亡已经够难了。当然，这就是我们想要的。泰勒和他的兄弟制作葬礼视频才几年。他们绝对认为这是一项正在进行的工作，他们还在摸索中。但所有这些关于你如何保存记忆的思考，促使泰勒开始收集他自己的剪贴簿，记录他自己的生活。他在办公室里保存了两本这样的相册。当我让他翻看页面时，他翻到一张照片，这让他讲了这个故事。
It's a story which starts off at a family vacation and ends up at this cemetery, at his job, at this video project. The photo is of a fishing boat called La Victoria , taken on vacation when Tyler was just a teenager.
这是一个从家庭度假开始，最后在这个墓地，在这个工作，在这个视频项目结束的故事。照片是一艘叫“维多利亚号”的渔船，拍摄于泰勒十几岁度假时。
And that's my father that you can make out there. And unknown to me, my mother had found a letter from a girl I know. And she was writing this long plea to me to realize that I wasn't actually gay, because I had told her that I was gay. So for the first three days of this trip, everyone in the family was treating me as though I had died or something. They would just kind of not speak directly to me, and they were having difficulty looking at me.
你能在那上面辨认出我父亲。我当时不知道，我母亲发现了我认识的一个女孩写给我的信。她写了一封长长的信请求我意识到我其实并不是同性恋，因为我告诉过她我是同性恋。所以在那次旅行的前三天，家里的每个人对待我，就像我死了或者什么一样。他们只是不直接跟我说话，他们看着我的时候都很困难。
And so my mother concocted this plan to get my father and I on this all-day fishing trip in which he was supposed to ask me at a certain point. And so here we are, being all macho on La Victoria .
于是我母亲想出了这个计划，让我父亲和我去参加这次全天钓鱼旅行，他本应该在某个时刻问我。于是我们就在这里，在“维多利亚号”上表现得特别大男子主义。
He's supposed to ask you, "are you gay?"
他本应该问你，“你是同性恋吗？”
Yes, on this fishing expedition. Which was funny in itself because it's this Hemingway-esque test of manhood to be out here. And I actually was the one to get the giant tuna. I was reeling in the tuna. It was exactly as you see in the movies. It was really hurting my hands. And people are gathered around me, wanting me to reel this in and egging me on.
是的，在这个钓鱼探险中。这本身就很有趣，因为它是一种海明威式的男子气概测试，出现在这里。我实际上是那个抓到巨型金枪鱼的人。我当时正在收金枪鱼线。这正如你在电影里看到的那样。我的手真的很疼。人们围在我身边，想让我把这条鱼拉上来，并怂恿我。
And then I finally get it up, and it's this big, beautiful, huge tuna-- actually, the one in this shot-- that's almost human-sized. And it was gorgeous. And it falls on the floor, and everyone gathers around it and stabs it. And I shriek, "don't kill it!" And it seemed like this very telling moment. And I don't know if that answered my father's question.
然后我终于把它弄上来了，这是一条美丽、巨大、巨大的金枪鱼——实际上，就是这张照片里的那条——它几乎有人那么大。它太漂亮了。它掉在地板上，每个人都围着它刺它。我尖叫道：“别杀它！”这似乎是一个非常有深意的时刻。我不知道这是否回答了我父亲的问题。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Tyler had moved to New York for college and stayed, partly to flee the family funeral business.
泰勒搬到纽约上大学并留了下来，部分是为了逃离家庭殡葬业。
Yeah. It was kind of ironic. I thought I was going to leave death finally. And a father's business who was all around caskets and death. And I went much deeper into the heart of death when I got there. I was gay, and I went there to come out, and New York seemed like a good place.
是的。这有点讽刺。我以为我终于可以离开死亡了。一个父亲的生意周围全是棺材和死亡。当我到那里时，我更深地进入了死亡的核心。我是同性恋，我去那里是为了出柜，纽约似乎是个好地方。
But I arrived in 1988, which was kind of the apex or the heart of the epidemic.
但我是在1988年抵达的，那是流行病的顶点或核心。
The AIDS epidemic.
艾滋病流行。
The AIDS epidemic. Everyone was in the mourning. Everybody knew someone who was dying. There was always the thought that we could be dying because everyone was.
艾滋病流行。每个人都在哀悼。每个人都认识正在死去的人。总有人会想到我们可能会死，因为每个人都在死。
And so I think for a good six years, I was more obsessed about dying and death than I had ever been. And yet at same time, there's more people who didn't follow any type of tradition I had seen. Maybe some people threw a nightclub party, and that was in their will. You know, "I want you all to have fun. I want you all to dress in drag." Someone else had a dance ceremony, a poetry reading. The form kind of seemed broken.
所以我认为有整整六年，我比以往任何时候都更沉迷于死亡。然而与此同时，有更多的人没有遵循我见过的任何传统。也许有些人举办了夜店派对，那是在他们的遗嘱里。你知道，“我希望你们都玩得开心。我希望你们都变装。”还有人举行了舞蹈仪式、诗歌朗诵。形式似乎破碎了。
The form of a funeral?
葬礼的形式？
Of a funeral. And being broken, it was much more powerful and it served a purpose again. And I didn't ever think I was going to go home and return to the business, but it affected completely how I looked at it.
葬礼的形式。而且因为破碎，它强大得多了，并且再次发挥了作用。我从没想过我会回家并回到生意中，但这彻底改变了我看待它的方式。
You mean literally, you came to feel like the traditional funeral wasn't powerful enough to contain people's feelings?
你的意思是字面上，你开始觉得传统葬礼不足以容纳人们的感受？
Yeah. Definitely. The traditional funeral in terms of clergymen, one eulogy, and some last rites of some sort.
是的。绝对。传统葬礼是指牧师、一篇悼词，以及某种最后的仪式。
In Los Angeles, he couldn't have chosen a better spot for adding movies to funerals. The run-down cemetery he and his brother bought is where lots of luminaries from the first generation of motion pictures are buried-- people like Rudolph Valentino, Peter Lorre, Cecil B. Demille, Bugsy Siegel-- on a huge piece of land just next door to the Paramount Studios backlot. Just a short walk from where Norman and his colleagues edit these sort-of fake, sort-of real videotapes for eternity are the sound stages where the pleasingly sort-of fake, sort-of real worlds of Frasier and Moesha are filmed.
在洛杉矶，他不可能选到更好的地方来在葬礼上增加电影。他和兄弟买下的那个破败墓地，是许多第一代电影界的知名人物安葬的地方——比如鲁道夫·瓦伦蒂诺、彼得·洛、塞西尔·B·德米尔、巴格西·西格尔——就在派拉蒙制片厂外景地隔壁的一块巨大土地上。从诺曼和同事编辑这些半假、半真的永恒录像带的地方走不远，就是拍摄《欢乐一家亲》和《摩莎》那些令人愉快的半假、半真世界的地方。
As you walk through the cemetery, you see the intrusion of new technology here and there. Recent headstones made with photographs engraved right into the rock, made possible by a new kind of laser and computer technology. So far, it's mostly Russian and Armenian immigrants who go for this. A man named Simon King, in a jacket, no tie, stares out from his own tombstone with this bad-ass glare like, even though he has passed over to the other side, if you mess with him, he can still take you down.
当你走过墓地时，你会看到新技术的介入。最近的墓碑是用激光和电脑技术直接刻入石头中的照片。到目前为止，大多数是俄罗斯和亚美尼亚移民这样做。一个叫西蒙·金的男人，穿着夹克，没打领带，用那种强硬的凝视盯着他自己的墓碑，好像即使他已经到了另一边，如果你惹他，他仍然能干掉你。
Not far from there is one of the video touchscreens, in the shade by a wall. You can call up any video they've made. And we choose a name. It turns out to be a young woman, maybe 30. As the song "Can You Feel the Love Tonight?" plays, from The Lion King , photos flash by, 10 seconds each. Here she is in the hospital. Here she is in shot after shot with a baby that must be hers. Then more hospital photos, holding her baby, trying, trying to smile.
不远处就是其中一个视频触摸屏，在墙边的树荫下。你可以调用他们制作的任何视频。我们选了一个名字。那是一个年轻女子，大概30岁。随着《狮子王》里的《Can You Feel the Love Tonight?》响起，照片闪过，每张10秒。这是她在医院。这是她在一张又一张抱着一个肯定是她孩子的婴儿的照片。然后是更多医院照片，抱着她的孩子，试图，试图微笑。
It is impossibly sad, sadder than I can even convey to you here. There we are, in the bright Los Angeles sun, cars going by just yards away from us, a dead young mom on the TV, and we're mourning somebody we've never met. I think Tyler's right about all of this. I think if you were just walking by a stranger's tombstone and saw their name chiseled there on the rock, you'd never get this feeling. Coming up, it's my birthday and I'll lie if I want to. Or is it a lie? In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
这极其悲伤，悲伤到我甚至无法在这里向你们传达。我们就站在那明媚的洛杉矶阳光下，汽车从我们几码远的地方经过，电视上是一个死去的年轻母亲，而我们正在为一个我们从未见过的人哀悼。我想泰勒关于这一切是对的。我想如果你只是走过一个陌生人的墓碑，看到上面刻着的名字，你永远不会有这种感觉。接下来，这是我的生日，如果我想的话我会说谎。或者这是一个谎言？从公共广播国际台开始，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, to commemorate our fifth year on the air, birthdays, anniversaries, milestones of all sorts, how we mark them, what they mean even when we want them to mean nothing. Our program today taped on our fifth anniversary tour of New York, Boston, Chicago, and Los Angeles. And I have to say that we are honored at this point to have a special birthday greeting for the show, recorded by one of my radio heroes, Terry Gross of Fresh Air --
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，为了纪念我们播出五周年，生日、周年纪念、各种里程碑，我们如何标记它们，即使在我们想让它们毫无意义时它们意味着什么。我们的节目今天是在我们五周年巡回演出中录制的，地点是纽约、波士顿、芝加哥和洛杉矶。我不得不说，我们很荣幸能在这个时候为节目收到一份特别的生日贺词，由我的广播英雄之一，来自《新鲜空气》的泰瑞·格罗斯录制——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--which incredibly is celebrating its 25th year on the air this year. It makes us just look like little kids up here. She recorded this special message for us from her studio at WHYY in Philadelphia.
——令人难以置信的是，今年它正在庆祝播出25周年。这让我们看起来像这儿的孩子。她从费城WHYY的录音室为我们录制了这条特别信息。
[MATCH STRIKING] [CIGARETTE PUFF]
[划火柴声] [吸烟声]
Five years, huh? I suppose after five years I was still all bright-eyed and optimistic. You know, kid-- [CIGARETTE PUFF] --after 25 years in this crazy public radio game, you see a few things. And you see a side of people you sometimes wish you hadn't. Don't get me started. The booze, the drugs, the crazy parties, the fundraisers.
五年，是吧？我猜五年后我还是充满希望、头脑清醒。你知道，孩子——[吸烟声]——在这疯狂的公共广播游戏中待了25年后，你会看到一些事情。你会看到人们的一面，有时你希望自己没看到过。别让我开始说。酒水、毒品、疯狂派对、筹款活动。
[STIRRING AND SIPPING A DRINK]
[搅拌和啜饮饮料声]
Five years, huh? Well, you've got a lot to learn still, I guess. Yeah, congratulations. Whatever.
五年，是吧？嗯，我想你还有很多要学的。是的，祝贺。随它去吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hope you enjoy your cake.
希望你喜欢你的蛋糕。
Thank you, Terry Gross, for that kind message.
感谢泰瑞·格罗斯发来的友善信息。
Act Three, Birthday Present. There's a hotel in Salt Lake City called The Anniversary Inn. Before this building became an institution devoted to commemorating years of marriage, the building was the Salt Lake City jail. Insert your own cheap joke here. The idea of the hotel is on an anniversary or a birthday or other big day, what we want is fantasy. There's a room with a drawbridge and a knight in armor, designed to look like Sleeping Beauty's castle. There's a hayloft room and a Swiss Family Robinson tree house and a Treasure Island suite. That one has a ship's mast and a crow's nest and sails stretching across the room. You walk the gangplank to jump into a jacuzzi.
第三幕，《生日礼物》。盐湖城有一家酒店叫“周年纪念客栈”。在这个建筑成为致力于纪念婚姻年份的机构之前，它是盐湖城监狱。在这里插入你自己的廉价笑话吧。这家酒店的理念是，在周年纪念、生日或其他大日子里，我们想要的是幻想。有一个带吊桥和盔甲骑士的房间，设计看起来像睡美人的城堡。有干草棚房、瑞士家庭鲁滨逊树屋和金银岛套房。那一间有船桅、瞭望塔和横跨房间的帆。你走过跳板跳进按摩浴缸。
I bring all this up because I think of The Anniversary Inn as a testament to the difficulty of introspection. It's as if when a big, commemorative day arrives, the notion of using that moment to look back, to take stock, to try to gain a perspective on who we've been and who we are, that notion is so inherently difficult and possibly painful that many of us, we prefer to leave reality completely. Looking back, though, can be what we need more than anything. Russell Banks has this story. He is the author of numerous books. We are honored to have him. Please welcome him.
我提出这一切是因为我认为“周年纪念客栈”是对内省困难的证明。这就好像当一个盛大的纪念日到来时，利用那一刻回首往事、盘点一下、试图对我们曾经是谁和我们是谁获得某种视角，那个想法是如此内在困难且可能痛苦，以至于我们许多人更喜欢彻底离开现实。然而，回首往事可能是我们最需要的。罗素·班克斯有这个故事。他是众多书籍的作者。我们很荣幸邀请到他。欢迎他。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
It's about 10:00 PM, and I'm one of three, face it, middle-aged guys crossing South Main Street in light snow headed for a quick drink at the Greek's. We've just finished a 32nd degree induction ceremony at the Masonic Hall in the old Capitol Theater building and need a blow. I'm the tall figure in the middle, Warren Low. And I guess it's my story I'm telling, although you could say it was Gail Fortunata's story, since meeting her that night after half a lifetime is what got me started.
大约晚上10点，我是三个——面对现实吧——中年的家伙，冒着小雪穿过南主街，前往希腊餐厅喝杯快酒。我们刚结束在老国会剧院建筑里共济会大厅举行的第32度授予仪式，需要放松一下。我是中间那个高个子，沃伦·洛。我想是我在讲我的故事，尽管你也可以说这是盖尔·福尔图纳塔的故事，因为那天晚上在半辈子之后见到她，才让我开始了讲述。
I'm wearing remnants of makeup from the ceremony, in which I portrayed an Arab prince-- red lips, streaks of black on my face here and there, not quite washed off because of no cold cream at the hall. The guys tease me about what a terrific nigger I make. That's the way they talk. And I try to deflect their teasing by ignoring it, because I'm not as prejudiced as they are, even though I'm pleased nonetheless. It's an acting job, the 32 Degree, and not many guys are good at it. We are friends and businessmen, colleagues. I sell plumbing and heating supplies, my friend Sammy Gibson is in real estate, and the other, Rick Buckingham, is a Chevy dealer.
我带着仪式上用来化妆的残余，我在仪式上扮演了一位阿拉伯王子——红色的嘴唇，脸上这里那里有黑色条纹，没洗掉，因为大厅里没有冷霜。那些家伙取笑我演的黑鬼有多棒。他们就是那样说话的。我试图忽视他们的嘲笑来化解，因为我并不像他们那样有偏见，尽管我还是感到高兴。这是一项演艺工作，32度，没几个人能演好。我们是朋友和商人，同事。我销售管道和供暖用品，我的朋友萨米·吉布森做房地产生意，另一个，瑞克·白金汉，是雪佛兰经销商。
We enter the Greek's, a small restaurant and fern bar, pass through the dining room into the bar in back like regulars, because we are regulars, greeting the Greek and his help, small comforts. Sammy and Rick hit uselessly on one of the waitresses, the pretty little blond kid, and make a crack or two about the new gay waiter who's in the far corner by the kitchen door and can't hear them. Wise guys.
我们进入希腊餐厅，这是一家Fern Bar小餐馆，穿过餐厅进入后面的酒吧，就像常客一样，因为我们确实是常客，问候希腊老板和他的帮手，小小的慰藉。萨米和瑞克在那儿徒劳地撩一个女服务员，那个漂亮的金发小孩，并对远角厨房门边那个听不见他们说话的新同性恋服务生开了几句玩笑。精明的家伙。
The Greek says to me, "what's with the greasepaint?"
希腊老板对我说：“你的油彩怎么回事？”
"Theatre group," I tell him. He's not a Mason. I think he's orthodox Catholic or something. But he knows what we do.
“戏剧小组，”我告诉他。他不是共济会成员。我想他是东正教徒还是什么的。但他知道我们在做什么。
As we pass one table in particular, this elderly lady in the group looks me straight in the eyes, which gets my attention because otherwise she's just some old lady. Then for a split second, I think I know her, but decide not and keep going. She's a large, baggy, bright-eyed woman in her late 70s, possibly early 80s. Old.
当我们经过其中一张桌子时，那个组里的老妇人直直地看着我的眼睛，这引起了我的注意，因为否则她只是某个老太太。然后有一瞬间，我想我认识她，但决定没有，继续走。她是一个高大、衣着宽松、目光明亮的女人，70多岁，可能80出头。老了。她和家人在一起，某种庆祝。看起来有两个儿子，40多岁，带着妻子，还有一个无聊的十几岁女孩，五个人都超重、迟钝、孝顺。与那位老妇人形成对比，尽管她年纪大了，看起来聪明、清醒，穿着一件栗色针织羊毛套装。显然曾经是个很有魅力的女人。
Sammy, Rick, and I belly up to the bar, order drinks, the usuals, comment on the snow outside, and feel safe and contented in each other's company. We reflect on our wives and ex-wives and our grown kids, all elsewhere.
我从萨米和瑞克身边走开，问希腊老板，“那位老太太是谁？什么场合？”
I peek around the divider at her. Thin, silver-blue hair, dewlaps at her throat, liver spots on her long, flat cheeks. What the hell, an old lady. She's with family, some kind of celebration. Two sons, they look like, in their 40s with their wives, and a bored teenage girl, all five of them overweight, dull, dutiful. In contrast to the old woman, who despite her age, looks smart, aware, all dressed up in a maroon knit-wool suit. Clearly an attractive woman once.
“老太太80大寿，”希腊老板说。“我们应该活那么久，对吧？你认识她？”
I drift from Sammy and Rick, and ask the Greek, "who's the old lady? What's the occasion?"
“不，我想不认识。”女服务员和同性恋服务生唱着《生日快乐》，搞出了个场景，但因为雪，餐馆几乎空无一人，每个人似乎都喜欢这样，老太太平静地微笑着。
"The old lady's 80th," says the Greek. "We should live so long, right? You know her?"
我对萨米和瑞克说：“我觉得我认识那位老太太，但不记得在哪儿了。”
"No, I guess not." The waitresses and the gay waiter sing "Happy Birthday," making a scene, but the place is almost empty anyhow from the snow, and everybody seems to like it, and the old lady smiles serenely.
“客户，”萨米嚼着花生说。
I say to Sammy and Rick, "I think I know the old gal from someplace but can't remember where."
瑞克也说了同样的话，“客户，”然后他们像以前一样继续。
"Customer," says Sammy, munching peanuts.
“大概是个旧情人，”萨米补充说。
Rick says the same, "customer," and they go on as before.
“哈哈，”我回道。电视上的凯尔特人队对尼克斯队的比赛吸引了他们的注意，双加时。最终，尼克斯队赢了，该回家了，伙计们。雪越积越厚。我们穿上外套，结了账，当我们离开时，老太太的一行人也准备走。当我经过他们的桌子时，她抓住了我的袖子，叫出我的名字，用疑问句叫道。“沃伦？沃伦·洛？”
"Probably an old girlfriend," Sammy adds.
我说：“是的，嘿，”笑着，但我还是不记得她。
"Ha-ha," I say back. A Celtics-Knicks game on TV has their attention, double overtime. Finally, the Knicks win and it's time to go home, guys. The snow is piling up. We pull on our coats, pay the bartender, and as we leave, the old lady's party is also getting ready to go. And when I pass their table, she catches my sleeve, says my name, says it with a question mark. "Warren? Warren Low?"
然后她说：“我是盖尔·福尔图纳塔。沃伦，我几年前认识你，”她说，笑着，满是深情。然后一切都回来了，或者几乎一切。“你记得我吗？”她问。“当然，当然，我记得。盖尔。你怎么样了？天哪。过去很久了。”
I say, "yeah, hi," and smile, but still I don't remember her.
她点点头，仍然微笑着。“你脸上那是什么？化妆品？”
Then she says, "I'm Gail Fortunata. Warren, I knew you years ago," she says, and she smiles fondly. And then everything comes back, or almost everything. "Do you remember me?" she asks. "Sure, sure, I do. Of course I do. Gail. How have you been? Jeez. It's been a while."
“是的，一直在演一点戏。没冷霜把它们都洗掉，”我笨拙地说。
She nods, still smiling. "What's that on your face? Make up?"
她说：“我很高兴你还在演戏。”然后她就这样把我介绍给她的家人。“这是我的家人。”
"Yeah, been doing a little theater. Didn't have any cold cream to get it all off," I say, lamely.
“你们好，”我说，开始把我的朋友萨米和瑞克介绍给他们，但他们已经到门口了。
She says, "I'm glad you're still acting." And then she introduces me to her family, like that. "This is my family."
萨米说：“再见，沃伦。别做我不做的事。”瑞克挥了挥手，他们就出去了。
"Howdy," I say, and start to introduce my friends Sammy and Rick, but they're already at the door.
“所以是你的生日，盖尔。生日快乐。”
Sammy says, "so long, Warren. Don't do anything I wouldn't do." And Rick gives a wave, and they're out.
她说：“噢，谢谢。”其他人现在都站起来了，穿上外套，除了盖尔，她还没放开我的袖子，她拽了拽，然后对我说：“沃伦，坐一会儿。我大概有30年没见你了。想象一下。”
"So it's your birthday, Gail. Happy birthday."
“妈，”儿子说，“太晚了。还有雪。”
She says, "why, thank you." The others are all standing now, pulling on their coats, except for Gail, who still hasn't let go of my sleeve, which she tugs, and then says to me, "sit down a minute, Warren. I haven't seen you in, what, 30 years. Imagine."
我在盖尔旁边拉了一把椅子，丢掉那些愚蠢的伪装，我突然发现自己拼命想在她眼中看到那个我年轻时认识的女人，那是我刚21岁，她快50岁并已婚，而这两个胖家伙是她瘦弱的十几岁儿子时。但我无法透过老妇人的脸看到当年的那个女人。如果那个女人不在了，那那个男孩，那个男孩也不在了。
"Ma," the son says, "it's late. The snow."
她抬头看着其中一个儿子说：“迪基，你先走吧。沃伦会载我一程，是吧，沃伦？”她转头对我说道。“我住在迪基在山上的家里。这不顺路吗？”
I draw up a chair next to Gail, and letting go of the dumb pretenses, I suddenly find myself struggling to see in her eyes the woman I knew for a few months when I was a kid, barely 21, and she was almost 50 and married, and these two fat guys were her skinny teenage sons. But I can't see through the old lady's face to the woman she was then. If that woman is gone, then so is the boy, this boy.
“不，我也住在山上。奥尔顿伍兹。刚搬进那里的公寓。”
She looks up at one of her sons and says, "Dickie, you go without me. Warren will give me a ride, won't you, Warren?" she says, turning to me. "I'm staying at Dickie's house up on the heights. That's not out of your way, is it?"
迪基说：“好吧，”有点担心。他看起来习惯于输掉和母亲的争论。
"No, I'm up on the heights too. Alton Woods. Just moved into a condo there."
希腊老板和他的员工开始打扫，我和盖尔又谈了几分钟。虽然她的眼睛湿润且红肿，但她没有流泪。她在微笑。就好像她明亮的蓝色眼睛上有一层半透明的壳。即便如此，现在，当我努力观察时，我能瞥见她当年的模样，滑行在背后的阴影里。她有厚重、深红色的头发，像瓷器一样光滑、洁白的皮肤，宽阔的肩膀。对于女人来说，她很高，几乎和我一样高。我记得很清楚，有一次她和丈夫带我参加一个退伍军人聚会，她和我跳舞，而他在打牌。
Dickie says, "fine," a little worried. He looks like he's used to losing arguments with his mother.
“我们认识的时候，沃伦，我是你现在的年纪。”
The Greek and his crew start cleaning up while Gail and I talk a few minutes more. Although her eyes are wet and red-rimmed, she's not teary. She's smiling. It's as if there are translucent shells over her bright, blue eyes. Even so, now, when I look hard, I can glimpse her the way she was, slipping around back there in the shadows. She had heavy, dark red hair, clear, white skin, smooth as porcelain, broad shoulders. And she was tall for a woman, almost as tall as I was. I remember exactly, from when she and her husband once took me along with them to a VFW party, and she and I danced while he played cards.
“是的，我想是这样。想想看，这很奇怪，不是吗？”
"When we knew each other, Warren, I was the age you are now."
“你离婚了吗？你看上去像。”
"Yeah, I guess that's so. Strange to think about, isn't it?"
“是的，离婚了。有几年了。有孩子。三个女儿，都长大了。我甚至是个爷爷了。那可不是什么幸福的婚姻。差得远呢。”
"Are you divorced? You look like it."
“我想我不想听那些。”
"Yeah, divorced. Couple of years now. Kids. Three girls, all grown up. I'm even a grandpa. It was not one of your happy marriages. Not by a long shot."
“好吧。你想听什么？”
"I don't think I want to hear about all that."
“喝杯酒，聊会儿天，为了旧日情谊。然后你可以送我回我儿子家。”
"OK. What do you want to hear about?"
我说：“好的，”并问正在登记台敲账单的希腊老板现在喝杯睡前酒是不是太晚了。
"Let's have one drink and one short talk, for old time's sake. And then you may drive me to my son's home."
他耸耸肩。“为什么不呢？”盖尔要了一杯雪利酒，我点了通常喝的伏特加加奎宁水。希腊老板快步走回吧台，亲自倒了酒，因为调酒师正在擦冷却器，回来放在我们面前。“请客，”他说，又回去数晚上的收入。
I say, "fine," and ask the Greek, who's at the register tapping out if it's too late for a nightcap.
“奇怪，不是吗，我们之前从来没碰过面，”她说。“这些年你来到康科德，我留在朴茨茅斯，即使在孩子们离开后。弗兰克的工作在那里。”
He shrugs. "Why not?" And Gail asks for a sherry and I order the usual, vodka and tonic. The Greek scoots back to the bar, pours the drinks himself because the bartender is wiping down the cooler, and returns and sets them down before us. "On the house," he says, and goes back to counting the night's take.
“是的，嗯，我猜50英里有时候是很长的路。弗兰克怎么样？”我问，意识到我一说出口，他就至少比她大10岁，现在可能已经去世了。
"It's odd, isn't it, that we never ran into each other before this," she says. "All these years you came up here to Concord, and I stayed there in Portsmouth, even after the boys left. Frank's job was there."
“他死了。弗兰克死于1982年。”
"Yeah, well, I guess 50 miles is a long way sometimes. How is Frank?" I ask, realizing as soon as I say it that he was at least 10 years older than she and is probably dead by now.
“噢，天哪。听到这个我很遗憾。”
"He died. Frank died in 1982."
“我想问你点事，沃伦。希望你不会介意我私下和你说话。”
"Oh, Jeez. I'm sorry to hear that."
“没问题。说吧。”我喝了一口我的酒。
"I want to ask you something, Warren. I hope you won't mind if I speak personally with you."
“那时我从来不敢问你。我想这会让你尴尬，因为你对自己所做的事情感到害怕，对自己非常不自信。”
"No. Shoot." I take a belt from my drink.
“是的，没开玩笑。我当时，大概21岁。你，嗯，不吓人，但我们说给人印象深刻。已婚，有孩子，一个我眼中的世故的女人。而我只是这个管道工学徒，做着我的第一份工作，远离家乡，一个孩子。”
"I never dared to ask you then. It would have embarrassed you then, I thought, because you were so scared of what we were doing together, so unsure of yourself."
“你不仅是那样，沃伦。这就是为什么我那么容易就喜欢上你。你非常敏感。我想总有一天你会成为著名的演员。我想鼓励你。”
"Yeah, no kidding. I was, what, 21. You were, well, not scary, but let's say impressive. Married with kids, a sophisticated woman of the world, you seemed to me. And I was this apprentice plumber, working on my first job, away from home, a kid."
“你鼓励了吗？”我紧张地笑，因为我不知道这段对话要往哪里走，又喝了一口酒，说：“这些年来我演过很多戏，你知道。全是本地的。有些相当严肃。没什么大不了的。但我坚持了下来。当然，如今我没演太多。但你确实鼓励过我，盖尔。你确实。我真的很感激。”
"You were more than that, Warren. That's why I took to you so easily. You were very sensitive. I thought someday you'd become a famous actor. I wanted to encourage you."
她像只鸟一样抿着嘴唇喝雪利酒。“很好，”她说。“沃伦，我们认识你的时候，你是处男吗？”
"You did?" I laugh nervously, because I don't know where this conversation is going and take another pull from my drink and say, "I've done lots of acting over the years, you know. All local stuff. Some of it pretty serious. No big deal. But I kept it up. I don't do much nowadays, of course. But you did encourage me, Gail. You did. And I'm truly grateful for that."
“噢，天哪。嗯，那，那真是一个问题，不是吗？”我笑道。“这些年来你一直都在好奇这个吗？我是你唯一一个做爱的女人吗？哇，那真——嘿，盖尔，我不觉得之前有人问过我这个。而我们现在在这里，30年后。”我微笑着看着她，但空气正从我身体里流逝。
She sips her sherry with pursed lips, like a bird. "Good," she says. "Warren, were you are virgin then, when you met me?"
“我只是想知道，亲爱的。你从没说过是或不是。我们分享了一个巨大的秘密，但我们从没真正谈论过我们自己的秘密。我们谈论戏剧，我们有过那段短暂的恋情，然后你离开了。而我留在了弗兰克身边并变老。变老了。”
"Oh, jeez. Well, that's, that's quite a question, isn't it?" I laugh. "Is that what you've been wondering all these years? Were you the first woman I ever made love with? Wow, that's-- hey, Gail, I don't think anybody's ever asked me that before. And here we are, 30 years later." I'm smiling at her, but the air is rushing out of me.
“你那时候不老。”
"I just want to know, dear. You never said it one way or the other. We shared a big secret but we never really talked about our own secrets. We talked about the theater and we had our little love affair and then you went on. And I stayed with Frank and grew old. Older."
“和你现在一样老，沃伦。”
"You weren't old."
“是的，但我并不老。”
"As old as you are now, Warren."
“好吧，你是吗？”
"Yeah, but I'm not old."
“什么，处男？”
"Well, were you?"
“如果你尴尬的话，你不必回答。”我忍了几秒钟。女服务员、新来的小孩和调酒师都走了，只有希腊老板待在这里，栖在吧台的凳子上看着《夜线》。我可以告诉她实话，或者我可以撒谎，或者我可以完全避开这个问题。很难知道什么才是对的。
"What, a virgin?"
最终，我说：“是的，我是。我遇见你时还是处男。那是我第一次，”我告诉她。她向后靠在椅子上，直直地看着我的脸，微笑着，就像我刚刚给了她一份完美的生日礼物一样。那种没有其他人想过她想要的。
"You don't have to answer if it embarrasses you." I hold off a few seconds. The waitress and the new kid and the bartender have all left, and only the Greek is here, perched on a stool in the bar, watching Nightline. I could tell her the truth or I could lie or I could beg off the question altogether. It's hard to know what's right.
[笑声]
Finally, I say, "yes, I was. I was a virgin when I met you. It was the first time for me," I tell her. And she sits back in her chair and looks me full in the face and smiles, as if I've just given her the perfect birthday gift. The one no one else thought she wanted.
她从未敢要求得到的礼物。这是一个美丽的微笑，感激而骄傲，似乎一直回到了我们第一次见面的那一天。她伸过手，把她那只粗糙的小手放在我的手上。她说：“我从来不知道确定答案。但每当我想起那些日子，想起我们过去如何在你房间见面时，我总是假装那对你来说是第一次。我甚至在当时发生的时候也假装过。这对我很重要。”
[LAUGHTER]
片刻间，我们谁都没说话。然后我打破了沉默。“我们走吧，你说呢？他们需要关门了，雪下得很大。”她同意了，我帮她套上外套。我的车只停在半个街区远，但走过去很慢，因为人行道有点滑，她很小心。
The gift she never dared to ask for. It's a beautiful smile, grateful and proud, and seems to go all the way back to the day we first met. She reaches over and places her small, crackled hand on mine. She says, "I never knew for sure. But whenever I think back on those days and remember how we used to meet in your room, I always pretend that for you it was the first time. I even pretended it back then, when it was happening. It meant something to me."
当我们上车并在主街北上行驶时，我们沉默了片刻。最后，我对她说：“你知道吗，盖尔？有件事这些年来我也一直很好奇。”
For a few moments, neither of us speaks. Then I break the spell. "What do you say we shove off? They need to close this place up and the snow's coming down hard." She agrees, and I help her slide into her coat. My car is parked only halfway down the block, but it's a slow walk to it because the sidewalk is a little slippery and she's very careful.
“有吗？”
When we're in the car and moving north on Main Street, we remain silent for a while. And finally, I say to her, "you know, Gail? There's something I've wondered all these years myself."
“是的，但如果你尴尬的话，你不必告诉我。”
"Is there?"
“沃伦，亲爱的，到了某个年纪，什么都不会让你尴尬。”
"Yeah, but you don't have to tell me if it embarrasses you."
“是的，嗯，我想那是真的。”
"Warren, dear, you reach a certain age, nothing embarrasses you."
“是什么？”
"Yeah, well, I guess that's true."
“好吧。我想知道除了我，你对弗兰克是否忠诚。还有在我之前。”
"What is it?"
没有犹豫。她说：“是的，在你之前和之后，我对弗兰克都很忠诚。除了我丈夫，你是我唯一爱过的男人。”我不相信她，但我知道她为什么要对我撒谎。这次轮到我微笑，伸出手把我的手放在她的手上。
"OK. I wondered if except for me you stayed faithful to Frank. And before me."
剩下的路我们没说话，除了她给我指路去她儿子家，那是在老军械库附近一条弯曲侧街上的一个普通砖房牧场。门廊灯亮着，但房子的其他部分很暗。“太晚了，”我对她说。
No hesitation. She says, "yes, I was faithful to Frank before you and after. Except for my husband, you were the only man I loved." I don't believe her, but I know why she has lied to me. This time it's my turn to smile and reach over and place my hand on hers.
“确实。”我下车绕过去帮她从车里出来，然后陪她沿着小路走到门口。她从钱包里拿出钥匙，打开门，转过身抬头看着我。她没以前那么高了。“很高兴我们今晚见了一面，”她说。“我们可能不会再见面了。”
The rest of the way we don't talk, except for her giving me directions to her son's house, which is a plain brick ranch on a curving side street up by the old armory. The porch light is on, but the rest of the house is dark. "It's late," I say to her.
“嗯，我们可以，如果你想的话。”
"So it is." I get out and come around and help her from the car and then walk her up the path to the door. She gets her key from her purse and unlocks the door and turns around and looks up at me. She's not as tall as she used to be. "I'm very happy that we saw each other tonight," she says. "We probably won't see each other again."
“你仍然是一个非常甜蜜的人，沃伦。我很高兴。我没看错你。”我不知道该说什么。但我确实想吻她。我低下头，抱住她，轻轻地吻了她的嘴唇。然后又深了一点。她吻了回来，带着足够的力度让我知道她也在回想着一切。我们就这样抱了很久。
"Well, we can, if you want to."
然后我退开，她转身，打开门，最后看了一眼我。她微笑着。“你脸上还有化妆品，”她说。“戏叫什么名字？我忘了问。”
"You're still a very sweet man, Warren. I'm glad of that. I wasn't wrong about you." I don't know what to say. I want to kiss her, though. And I do. I lean down, put my arms around her, and kiss her on the lips very gently. Then a little more. And she kisses me back with just enough pressure against me to let me know that she is remembering everything too. We hold each other like that for a long time.
“噢，”我快速思考着，因为我记得她是天主教徒，可能对共济会没什么好感。“奥赛罗，”我说。
Then I step away and she turns, opens the door, and takes one last look back at me. She smiles. "You've still got makeup on," she says. "What's the play? I forgot to ask."
“真好。你是那个摩尔人？”
"Oh," I say, thinking fast, because I'm remembering that she's Catholic and probably doesn't think much of the Masons. "Othello," I say.
“是的。”她依然微笑着，挥了挥手，就像在打发我走，然后进去了。
"That's nice. And you're the moor?"
开车回家时，我强忍着泪水。时间来了，时间走了，时间永不复返，我对自己说。我决定，眼前的一切就是我所拥有的一切。当我开车穿过风雪时，这一切似乎并不多，除了我刚刚与一位老妇人交换的友善。所以我专注于那点。谢谢你们。
"Yes." Still smiling, she gives me a slow, pushing wave with her hand, as if dismissing me, and goes inside.
[掌声]
Driving home, it's all I can do to keep from crying. Times come, times gone, times never returning, I say to myself. What's here in front of me is all I've got, I decide. And as I drive my car through the blowing snow, it doesn't seem like much, except for the kindness that I've just exchanged with an old lady. So I concentrate on that. Thank you.
罗素·班克斯。他的故事《摩尔人》发表在他的最新小说集《屋顶上的天使》中。
[APPLAUSE]
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，参与者有托德·巴赫曼、斯塔莉·凯恩、亚历克斯·布隆伯格、布鲁·切维尼和乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。Erin Yanke提供制作协助。
Russell Banks. His story, "The Moor," is published in his latest collection of short fiction, The Angel on the Roof.
OK Go。达米安·库拉什，愤世嫉俗的那一个。蒂姆·诺德温德，开心的那一个。丹·科诺普卡，稳重的那一个。安德鲁·邓肯，安静的乔治·哈里森型。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Todd Bachmann, Starlee Kine, Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, and Jonathan Goldstein. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Erin Yanke.
[致谢]
OK Go. Damian Kulash, the cynical one. Tim Nordwind, the happy one. Dan Konopka, the solid one. Andrew Duncan, the quiet, George Harrison type.
你可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org免费收听我们的节目。本节目由公共广播国际台发行。WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚，他在每期节目的最后都对我们说——
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
是的，祝贺。随它去吧。
You can listen to our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says to us at the end of each and every show--
[掌声]
Yeah, congratulations. Whatever.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
[资助名单]
[APPLAUSE]
本周在我们的网站上，我们为听众举办了一场比赛，邀请他们混音、重新演绎或重新想象斯塔莉·凯恩几个月前的那首分手歌。投票已经结束，结果已经出来，选票已经计算完毕。赢家现在在thisamericanlife.org，供你们聆听心碎的快乐。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
PRI，公共广播国际台。
And at our website this week, we held a contest for listeners to remix, re-perform or re-imagine Starlee Kine's break-up song from a few months back. Well, the polls have closed, the votes are in, the ballots are counted. The winners are now at thisamericanlife.org for your listening heartbreak pleasure.
本周在我们的网站上，我们举办了一场比赛，邀请听众为 Starlee Kine 几个月前创作的那首分手歌进行混音、重新演绎或重新构思。现在投票已经结束，结果已经出炉，票数也已统计完毕。获胜作品现已发布在 thisamericanlife.org 上，供您尽情聆听并感受那份心碎。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。